it all started in 2011 when the European
Commission drafted a proposal to
establish an eu-wide passenger name
record or P&R the record aims to allow
Member States authorities to access
airline personal information on
passengers traveling outside the EU the
information would be used for the
purposes of prevention detection
investigation and prosecution PNR is an
important tool in the fight against
trafficking organized crime and
terrorism it is not a silver bullet nor
have I agreed it in response to one
specific attack however horrific that
might have been national authorities can
store pee in our data for up to five
years for the first six months the data
will be unmasked meaning the name
contact information and address of a
passenger will be visible at first
member states wanted information to be
visible for a two-year period but MEP is
push to get it down to six months in an
effort to strike a balance between
privacy and security in the fight
against terrorism